[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as we make the awkward segue into uh
the number one team in the country and
nick saban
set to joining us on the program i you
know i'll talk about that in a moment
coach
um we were just talking about you know
when's the last time you went christmas
shopping
i usually once a year
um i have a lady that i'll meet at the
store
and i might give her a hundred dollar
bill and a list of things to get from
miss terry
and uh she brings it back to me all
wrapped up and we're ready to roll
i don't know if it's a hundred dollars
it feels like it might be a little more
than that coach
right but i mean i need assistance to
shop i guess is the key to the drill
now is it required that the assistant
coaches get you a gift
um they usually do
and i we usually get them
a gift as well as their wives
i think sometimes wives get
overlooked uh in coaching because they
have to be so supportive
and in college you know they're involved
in recruiting
and relationship building
so sometimes they get overlooked
so i gotta make sure that at christmas
they know that
we appreciate what they do
how do you know you've had a good
recruiting year
um when they
when the puppy dogs grow up to become
you know real dogs then
you really kind of know um you think by
evaluation which
recruiting is probably a bit of an
inexact science i think evaluation of
players is an inexact science because
you can probably measure some of the
physical characteristics but you really
never know for sure
you know what the psychological
disposition is to
develop and compete relative to what
you're capable of i think that's
probably true in anything
not just sports but um it makes it a bit
of an inexact science so you really
don't know how
the players that you got were developed
you know where they are right now
they look like they're pretty good
relatively speaking
but how are they going to develop over
the next year or two or three
and what's their maturity level going to
be to
be able to compete and i think one of
the most
important things in development is
you know how do you accept the critical
eye you know people
who have goals and aspirations and
really want to accomplish something
they're always looking for people to
you know tell me what i need to do to
get better but then we have
you know quite a few folks that they've
had a lot of success
um so they look at it more
when they get corrected like it's
personally insulting
so it makes it harder for them to grow
and develop so all these factors sort of
you know come together to determine how
someone develops and
how early they're ready to contribute uh
and how quickly
um they actually develop the skill level
to be
kind of player capable band and i find
that really interesting you're talking
about and i have kids who are in their
early 20s
and and you're right how you can say
something and then how they accept it
and i was curious
how recruiting has changed for you over
the years what's the biggest difference
that you've seen
i i think that expectation
that the player has now is
a lot greater than it used to be which i
think is a little bit of an obstacle to
overcome
because i think when people have
expectations like i want to start as a
freshman
or i want to catch 50 passes or whatever
as a freshman and then those things
don't happen
readily because they are focused on
outcome-oriented type things and
not what they really need to do to get
the outcome
they get frustrated and when they get
frustrated um
you know they they don't perform as well
they don't develop as well
they don't improve because you know
they're got a negative attitude about
things so
um well social media has been i mean
that that's a big opponent that you have
to fight as well
of what people say to these kids and
they are kids and then how they react to
it
well and i think you're 100 right it's
it's the expectation that gets created
by social media and you know look 20
years ago we didn't have
all these recruiting ratings and five
star four star
but all these things create an
expectation and it's not it's not the
player it's not the young man's fault
that these expectations are created
externally but they do have an impact
and affect some guys
and they think they're failing if they
don't meet these
sort of i'm going to call them almost
false expectations because they're not
realistic in a lot of ways so it takes
away from this whole
process of thinking about what i have to
do to
develop and get results and become very
outcome oriented and disappointed if i
don't get the outcome that
people expect he's nick saban alabama
will play florida sec title game coming
up saturday night
who's the recruit you missed that you
still think about
you missed out
there's more than on well i asked tom
izzo at michigan state and he said he
missed out on chris webber and he said
he thinks
he thinks about it more than he should
but i didn't know if there's one that
you
you either see this guy or you think
about it and you go
how did i miss out on that guy
you know no one comes to mind readily
but um if i thought about it i'm sure
i'd come up with somebody
but you know i think one of the hardest
things in recruiting is
you really develop relationships with
certain players
um as you recruit them and it's very
very disappointing
um when you have a really close
relationship with a guy
and then the guy goes someplace else and
not only do you have that relationship
but now you gotta play against them
especially
and um so i i think that's
you know one of the the harder things
you know um leonard fournette comes to
mind you know i had a really good
relationship with him you know his mom
made crawfish at tufay when i went in
the house and it was the best ever and
all that and then
you know you think you got a chance to
get the kind and you don't it's kind of
i don't know it's a little disappointing
because of relationships not only you've
developed with players but also with
their family yeah and you have to ask
for seconds too with the uh
a twofey right don't want to offend mom
that's one thing about louisiana you
don't go on home business without eating
and if you have two and one nights you
gotta eat twice
who does kyle trask remind you of
oh nobody in particular he's really a
pretty
uh heady heads up very accurate
smart executes their offense well reads
things
he's got good players good system that
they play in
and he gets the ball to the right guys
in the right place
in the right circumstances and um
it's very very efficient very effective
and
they've got they've got a lot of
mismatched players which make it really
difficult to match up and they do a
really good job of putting them in
you know tough spots uh to get the right
people on them
we had your quarterback on a couple of
weeks ago and uh he's got a sneaky sense
of humor there coach
i we really liked him well mac yeah
he's good yeah very bright guy
um and um
you know as and i think he's used his
knowledge and experience to develop
to become the kind of player that he is
he said that wide open receivers are the
toughest to hit
well you know i played quarterback
back in high school in my first year of
college
i i tend to agree with him on that
because
you know it just runs through your mind
right before you throw it i can't mess
this up
and that's why you only played one year
in college probably
uh hey it's great to talk to you good
luck on saturday night when do you
decide your first play
do you know what your first play is
going to be uh we usually decide that
today
i mean we always have a script on
offense um
and you know the coordinators have you
know the biggest
input in that um but on defense you know
you
you it's a little different because you
don't know whether what personnel
they're going to be in
whether you're going to be playing
regular nickel you know you just
so you got to kind of have your call for
whatever they do
well it's great to talk to you happy
holidays good luck against
florida and uh whatever happens after
that coach always appreciate the time
all right dan thank you appreciate you
buddy have a good holiday thanks bye-bye
that's uh nick saban got a big game
coming up with florida
on saturday night you're pal yeah yeah
hey he makes time a couple times a year
he makes time to come on and i
appreciate that